our next speaker is eric weingarten now
eric is a postdoc at stanford and is
currently a research fellow in the pro
high dimensional probability program
eric
okay thanks prasad um so in this short
talk
i want to tell you guys about an
algorithms problem
which is taking place in some high
dimensional metric space so the
algorithms problem is the approximate
nearest neighbor problem
and i have this picture here to explain
what the problem is
basically we receive a data set and
think about this as just
n points in some high dimensional space
and what we want to do is we want to
pre-process it into a data structure
such that we can do
approximate similarity search so what
this means is that
after you pre-process your points
there's going to be a query which comes
in this is a blue point
in the center labeled q and the promise
is that there exists some point from the
data set
within distance r from the query so r is
some parameter and
x here is the point from the data set
which is closest to q
and now the task is to return any point
from the data set
within distance c times r from the query
so in the picture here this is the point
x
hat so distance c times r so if c is
bigger than one then you're returning an
approximate nearest neighbor
to the query point q and this problem
sort of shows up and it's really
parameterized by how we measure
distances
in the space so let me tell you about
maybe
one of the most well-known result in
this area which is
when the underlying metric space is the
l1 distance so this is in the next slide
this is a theorem of indica matuani from
1998 and it really shows like the goal
of what we really
want to from these data structures in
particular when p
equals one so this is the metric space
l1 where you take the sum of absolute
values
uh we can basically design a data
structure where the approximation factor
c is one over epsilon
the space is slightly super linear
basically d times
n to the one plus epsilon and the query
time is highly sublinear so we're trying
not to scan through the entire data set
think of epsilon as being like one half
this is time complexity square root n
okay so go to the next slide
on the other hand when we think of p as
being something large like the l
infinity distance suddenly the best
known algorithms that we have
running in sublinear time have to pay a
large factor
in the approximation in particular for p
equals infinity the best algorithm that
we know
that runs in sublinear time has
complexity which is
log log d
so this is much worse than the constant
approximation we got from
when p equals one okay so the next slide
okay so this is basically a picture of
the state of the art and where i
explained the
sort of the new result so we have in the
the y-axis here represents the
approximation factor
and p is represents the the x-axis so we
go from p equals 1
on the lower left getting the constant
approximation to
p equals infinity um
all the way on the right and this
basically this curve
that is supposed to be sort of like log
d is supposed to indicate the
conjectured optimal
algorithm and the new result is that we
can actually match this conjectured
optimal whenever p is bigger than log
log d
this is like some technical reasons this
is the new result with
alexandoni sasho nikolov and elia
rajenstein
and at a high level you can think about
this as kind of interpolating between
the case for p equals one and p equals
infinity which even though
algorithmically look very different
there is a way to smoothly trade these
off and then i
am highlighting this green region here
because this is the open problem
this is still this um this area where we
don't quite have
what the conjectured optimal algorithm
is
yeah so that's the that's everything